cette gêne ce nom
c'est qui lité lauda il vient de signer
chez ferrari c'est un cri
icône du combat bien là tout de suite
sans aucune motivation pourquoi je
conduirai des maximois qui fait de
manger
fait une passe d'armes spectaculaire
la prochaine fois je ferai aucune chance
qu'un fêtards c'est pour ça que tout le
monde aime
je sais le chien vivable tu n'es pas
invivable tuer qu'ils tuent est un
moment crucial de taille
pour être champion il suffit pas d'être
le plus rapide il faut vraiment y croire
vu que je suis enfant je peux le battre
croyez moi il est régulier c'est à main
dessus et il mettra sa vie en jeu quand
la victoire à nos programmes
sans responsable de ce qui s'est passé
l'aide
mais crois moi j'étais regardé gagner
toutes ses courses est tout aussi
responsable de mon retour derrière le
volant
façon les familles
qui ont frôlé la mort tu ressens vivant